Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird Zeit, sich mal mit dem niederländischen Fußball auseinanderzusetzen und das wollen wir heute tun in Kurzpass Nummer 124 mit Jan Leerkes, einem Sportjournalisten aus dem Niederlanden, der unter anderem für den Kicker berichtet. Jan, sagen wir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Ja, vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit nimmst hier mal für den Rasenfunk. Und du hast ja auch einen eigenen Podcast, den wir an der Stelle natürlich erwähnen wollen. Was erwartet uns denn da?
Ja, meinen eigenen Podcast zusammen mit drei anderen heißt International Football News. Und das ist eine YouTube-Sendung, kann man sagen, wobei wir das internationale Fußball besprechen, wobei wir dann eine Moderatorin haben. Und dann ist Jan Hermen de Bruijn der Englandexperte, Jurian van Wessum der Südeuropa-Experte. Und ich gehe dann durchs Leben als den Mann, der vieles weiß über den deutschen Fußball. Das ist eigentlich auch, kann man sagen, wo ich mich am meisten unterscheide in der journalistischen Welt, den deutschen Fußball für den niederländischen Folge und den niederländischen Fußball für den deutschsprachigen Raum. Und daher sieht man zum Beispiel auch, dass ich sowohl in Niederländisch über den deutschen Fußball tittere, als in Deutsch über den niederländischen Fußball.
Genau, also dieser Podcast ist dann auch auf niederländisch. Aber ganz interessant, wenn man das niederländisch mächtig ist, dann bekommt man die andere Perspektive. Und wir Deutsche verstehen ja dann immer so Bruchstücke vom niederländischen. Also ich habe in die letzte Folge reingehört und habe über Robert Heutzer gehört. Und da wusste ich, es geht um HSV gegen Paderborn.
Also das bedeutet, wir haben natürlich über den deutschen Fußball diese Woche berichtet, über den Rekort-Transfers von Bayern mit Lucas Hernandez. Und dann habe ich auch noch gesagt, dass es mir leid tut für den Eintracht Frankfurt Anhänger, weil ich schon Wochen über die Erfolge von Eintracht sprechen will, aber immer wieder kommt etwas dazwischen. Und danach ist es dann weitergegangen über das Spiel von Dienstag. Und dann habe ich natürlich noch mal an dem Skandal um Roboteutsche erinnert. Aber das wird man in Deutschland noch viel mehr tun, als ich es kurz getan habe.
Jaja, aber es ist doch schön, dass wir hier auch internationale Podcasts mal empfehlen können. In eurem Podcast blickt ihr voraus. Wir wollen jetzt noch mal kurz zurückblicken, denn es gab ja das Aufeinandertreffen zwischen Niederlande und Deutschland. Am Ende ein 3 zu 2 nach einem Tor in der 90. Minute von Nico Schulz. Wie bewerten denn die niederländischen Medien und auch du dieses Spiel?
Es war eine Enttäuschung. Lass es mal klar sein, wenn man in der letzten Minute ein Unentschieden verspielt gegen Deutschen. Das passiert natürlich jedem, der gegen Deutsche spielt. Aber ja, es ist natürlich eine Enttäuschung. Aber man hat auch gesehen, dass vor allem die zweite Halbzeit wieder gut war. Und man sieht, dass die niederländische Nationalmannschaft Schritte macht. Und das ist eigentlich im Moment am wichtigsten. Und man sollte auch verstehen, dass was bei der Nations League los war, das war auch etwas mehr als man erwarten darf unter den momentanen Umständen. Weil normalerweise, ja die Niederlande haben ihre Gruppe gewonnen, aber normalerweise wird man diese Gruppe verlieren. Weil Frankreich ist natürlich sowieso eine der besten Mannschaften der Welt. Und Deutschland hat auch noch immer eine sehr gute Mannschaft. Und man muss auch sagen, dass die Niederlande in diesem Nations League Glück hatten. Wir waren wirklich die Besseren im Heimspiel gegen Frankreich. In Rotterdam haben die Niederlande sehr gut gespielt und auch Frankreich verdient geschlagen. Auswärts hat man verdient verloren. Und beide Spiele gegen Deutschland – ja, ich weiß, wie darauf in Deutschland reagiert worden ist. Und dass man vor allem sehr, sehr kritisch war über das Spiel in Amsterdam. Aber wenn man das Spiel – das war natürlich nicht nur für die Deutschen, aber auch für die Niederländer, weil Deutschland natürlich der Erzrival der Niederlande ist. Wenn man das ohne Emotionen zurückschaut, dann sieht man doch, dass Deutschland – lass man sagen – 80 Minuten die bessere Mannschaft war. Und wenn man dann 3 zu 0 gewinnt, muss man sagen, ok, das ist super. Aber dann ist man klug genug, um zu verstehen, dass man Glück hatte. Und das hatte man natürlich auch in Gelsenkirchen. Also wir haben zweimal Glück gehabt und jetzt war das Glück mal gegen uns.
Ja, aber wie kannst du – wie ordnest du das ein, dass vor allem die Anfangsphase von den Niederlanden so unterlegen gegenüber der deutschen Mannschaft war? Ab dann wurde es ja besser. Schon in der ersten Halbzeit klare Chancen auf den Anschlusstreffer und den Ausgleich. Und dann in der zweiten Halbzeit mit einer einfachen Umstellung, Joachim Löws Plan komplett ausgehebet. Und dann ein Schussverhältnis zwischen der 46. und der 80. Minute von 8 zu 0. Also da war der Niederlande drückend überlegen. Aber warum diese Anfangsphase?
Auf eine Art und Weise, seit Ronald Koeman Nationaltrainer ist, passiert dies sehr oft. Man kann sagen, dass in den meisten Spielen, seit er angefangen hat, die Niederlande schwach angefangen haben. Und dann haben sie sich später zurückgefunden. Also es ist etwas, was noch aus dieser Mannschaft rausgenommen werden muss. Aber das ist auch eine Entwicklung, wenn man eine neue Mannschaft formt. Dann geht das natürlich nicht gleich von 0 auf 100. Dann hat man auch immer Rückschläge und dann muss man etwas aufbauen. Das ist auch bei der niederländischen Nationalmannschaft im Moment so. Aber dies ist wirklich ein Problem. Normalerweise, was auch eigentlich gegen die Deutschen bestraft worden ist, kann in jedem Spiel passieren, was in der Schlussphase passiert ist. Aber man hatte natürlich diesen Start anders machen müssen. Aber was man sehr kritisch betrachtet und was man auch kritisch betrachten soll, ist der Fakt, dass die Niederlande eigentlich denselben Fehler gemacht haben in dem Heimspiel, als in dem letzten Auswärtsspiel in Gelsenkirchen, wo wir auch sehr lange an die Wand gespielt wurden von den Deutschen. Und dass man Frenkie de Jong zu weit nach hinten hat drücken lassen. Wir haben es auch in Kieke geschrieben in dem Bericht über den niederländischen Teil. Es war natürlich von Joachim Löw eine Schachtzug, die er gut geklappt hat, dass er angefangen hat mit Leon Goretzka. Das hatten nur wenige erwartet, auch in Deutschland selbst nicht. Aber Goretzka hat natürlich die Wege von Frenkie de Jong sehr gut eingeengt. Und das bedeutete, dass Frenkie de Jong zu weit nach hinten spielte. Und dass dann alles zu viel nach hinten fiel in den Niederlanden und den Anschluss nach vorne verloren ging. Ein anderer Teil war – und das ist auch, was die Niederlande im Moment, glaube ich, so gut machen – ist, dass Deutschland ohne wirklichen Mittelstürmer gespielt hat. Und das bedeutet, dass normalerweise spielen Van Dijk und de Licht gegen andere Typen, als dass sie jetzt mit Sane und Gnabry zu tun hatten. Und damit hatte man Mühe, so wie zum Beispiel auch unsere Gegner Mühe haben mit dem Fakt, dass Memphis Depay nicht an die Außenseite steht, aber zentral. Und von dieser zentralen Position eigentlich auf dem Feld wandert, auf dem Platz wandert. Also er geht – es ist seine Anfangsposition – aber er geht überall hin und dann kommt Babel in die Mitte und so weiter. Und da sah man zum Beispiel auch in dem zweiten Teil der ersten Halbzeit, dass ausgerechnet die beiden Großscienzen waren von Ryan Babel.
Genau. Und die Halbräume waren sowieso für beide Mannschaften total wichtig in der Partie. Jetzt mal losgelöst von diesem Spiel. Wenn ich mir die niederländische Mannschaft angucke, dann sieht man da unglaubliches Talent und auch richtig etablierte Spiele. Also über van Dijk muss man nicht sprechen. Frankie de Jong zeigt auch, was er kann und wird es bei Barcelona sicherlich auch zeigen. Aber dahinter fällt es dann schon ein bisschen ab. Und man hat ja auch diese Abhängigkeit im Spielaufbau von de Jong ja zum Beispiel auch gemerkt. In dem Moment, wo er aus dem Spiel genommen war oder die Wege zu weit waren für ihn dann, da hatte Niederlande in diesen Phasen wenig zu bringen. Wo siehst du denn die Mannschaft als Gesamtes?
Das ist, glaube ich, wenn man den letzten Jahren betrachtet, sehr schwierig. Weil der Punkt ist, die Niederlande sind in 2014 Dritter der Welt geworden, aber wir waren nicht Dritter der Welt. Und die beiden Turniere danach waren wir gar nicht bei der Endrunde, aber wir waren auch nicht das Land Nummer 20 von Europa. Also nachdem wir erstens zu gut waren, um es mal selbst zu sagen, für was wir wirklich waren, waren wir danach zu schlecht. Und im Moment glaube ich, dass die Niederlande etwas zu gut betrachtet werden, dank diesem Gewinn in der Nations League. Der Punkt ist, dass wir jetzt wieder bei der Nations League Final 4 sind, aber ich glaube nie, dass die Niederlande schon zu den Spitzen von Europa gehören. Normalerweise gewinnt man nicht gegen Länder wie Frankreich, Spanien oder England, weil die sind noch ein Niveau weit weg, aber das ist der Unterschied zwischen dem, was in 2016 und 2018 los war, und der Übereinstimmung mit 2014. Wir haben jetzt mit Ronald Koeman wieder einen Nationaltrainer. Der sehr praktisch denkt, der keine höhere Sachen will, er will nur gewinnen.
Er ist pragmatisch, genau. Und er will nicht sein System unbedingt durchsetzen, so wie zum Beispiel ein Van Raal.
Oder einen Peter Bosz zum Beispiel. Er ist ein anderer Typ. Peter Bosz ist jemand, der auch Ideale hat im Fußball und schön Fußball spielen will. Aber das hat Ronald Koeman nicht. Und obwohl Van Raal das auch hat, hat Van Raal in 2014 auch pragmatisch in Fußball gespielt, mit einem 3-5-2, was sehr gegen die niederländische Art von Fußballspielen ist. Und das ist eigentlich, was Ronald Koeman jetzt tut, auch gegen unsere traditionelle Art von Ballbesitzspielen, von angriffslustigen Spielen über die Flügel. Das können wir im Moment nicht, weil wir die Spiele nicht haben. Aber das Pragmatische an ihm ist, dass er dennoch eine Mannschaft geformt hat, die gegen jeden mithalten kann. Und das ist der große Unterschied, glaube ich. Wir sind, glaube ich, immer noch die Landnummer, was soll es sein, 8, 9, 10 von Europa. Aber obwohl man 8, 9, 10 ist, und lass mal sagen, vor drei Jahren 11, 12, 13, so weit ist der Unterschied nicht. Aber damals hatten wir, wenn es nicht lief, liefen es auch gar nicht. Und haben wir auch Punten verspielt. Und jetzt, als es nicht läuft, dann hat man immer noch ein Grundstück, worauf man zurückfallen kann und von da aus weiterbilden kann. Und dass man etwas geschlossener steht, etwas mehr in die Defensive gut betrachtet hat. Man muss übrigens auch sagen, zum Beispiel während der Qualifikation für die WM 2018 hatten die Niederlande auch unglaublich viel Pech und Schweden unglaublich viel Glück. Ich weiß nicht auf Deutsch, ob Sie das erinnern können, aber bei der Sieg der UEFA-Pokal 2002 von Feyenoord habe ich mal gesagt, als die Saison angefangen war, stand die Name Feyenoord-Schan auf dem Trophee. Weil alles war mit der Verein, alles ist glücklich gefallen. Und das war auch mit dem Schweden der Fall, weil zum Beispiel die Qualifikation hat angefangen und dann haben die in der letzten Minute einen ungerechten Unentschieden erreicht, weil ein Tor von Bas Dost nicht stattgegeben wurde. Und dann hat es auch diesen wahnsinnigen Fehler von Hugo Lloris gegeben beim Spiel Schweden-Frankreich. Wenn diese beiden Spiele normalerweise geendet hätten, hätte es Niederlande Italien gegeben in den Playoffs der WM 2018. Aber ja, das sind auch Sachen, die passieren. Weil zum Beispiel, das ist auch am letzten Montag, war es zwei Jahre her, dass Matthijs de Ligt sein Debüt gegeben hat in die Nationalmannschaft im Spiel gegen Bulgarien. Das war auswärts und das war eigentlich der Tiefpunkt der Niederlande in dem modernen Zeitalter, weil das Spiel endete 2 zu 0. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, dass es Spasev heißt, diesen Bulgaren, und er spielt in einem mittelklassigen Verein in Köln. Aber er hat zweimal gegen die Niederlande getroffen und Bulgarien hat verdient gewonnen in Sofia. Aber das war auch das Debüt von Matthijs de Ligt.
Und damals war er ja dann 17, also unglaublich jung. Das setzt doch auch den perfekten Spannungsbogen eigentlich. Wir sind am Tiefpunkt der Nationalmannschaft gegen Bulgarien. Und jetzt hast du gesagt, jetzt ist man schon an einem deutlich anderen Ort. Und das kann man ja auch an den Vereinsmannschaften festmachen. Als du gesagt hast, wir sind jetzt vielleicht Nummer 8, 9, 10 in Europa, dachte ich mir, ja, also unter den besten 8 ist jetzt zum Beispiel Ajax-Amsterdam. Nachdem man gegen Real Madrid gewonnen hat in der Champions League, lass mal so ein bisschen in den Vereinsfußball rüber wechseln. Ajax Real aus dem Wettbewerb genommen. Jetzt tritt man dann gegen Juve an. In der Liga sehe ich allerdings jetzt nach einer Niederlage gegen Alkmaar. Am letzten Spieltag hat man fünf Punkte Rückstand auf PSV. Wie ist da die Situation bei Ajax? Wie wichtig ist die Liga im Vergleich zu Champions League zum Beispiel?
Eigentlich ist die Liga am aller, aller, allerwichtigsten. Weil Ajax ist schon vier Jahre kein Meister mehr geworden. Und wenn man Rekordmeister ist, der größte Verein, der populärste Verein in einem Land, dann ist vier Jahre ohne Meistertitel zu lange. Also diesen Frust steckt im Moment tief. Und daher sieht man auch, das ist auch der eigentliche Grund, kann man sagen, diese vier Jahre ohne Titel, dass man im Sommer bei Ajax die Politik geändert hat und mit vor allem Tadic und Blind auch erstmals wirklich Topspieler für viel Geld eingekauft hat. Es hat am Anfang dieses Jahrzehnt eine Revolution gegeben, unter Anführung von Johann Greuf. Und diese Revolution hat auch mit sich gebracht, dass man wirklich wieder auf die Jugend gesetzt hatte. Und dass man wirklich gesagt hat, keine Großeinkaufen mehr, die Jugend soll es machen und alles dreht sich um die Jugend. Und nachdem man damit einige Titel gewonnen hat, aber international nicht wirklich den Durchbruch geschafft hat, hat man jetzt auch national gesehen, dass man vier Jahre schon kein Meister wurde, man wurde immer zweiter. Und daher hat man jetzt gesagt, okay, jetzt ist Schluss, wir kaufen ein und jetzt machen wir den großen Angriff. Der große Punkt im Fußball ist nur, dass man auch immer abhängig ist von dem Konkurrenz. Wenn du selbst Fehler machst, du machst Fehler auf Fehler, aber der direkte Konkurrenz macht noch mehr Fehler, dann ist man doch der größte und der beste. Wenn du selbst alles gut machst, aber der Konkurrenz macht auch alles gut, dann kann man doch als der Depp da stehen, obwohl man alles gut gemacht hat.
Ist das bei Ajax so? Sie haben ja auch schon viermal verloren in diesen bisherigen 26 Spielen. Das kann reichen zur Tabellenführung, aber vor allem diese Niederlage gegen Alkmaar und diese Niederlagen da zwischendurch rund um das Hinspiel gegen Real Madrid, wo man gegen Feyenoord 6 zu 2 verloren hat und dann gegen Heracles auch noch verloren hat. Das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen viel, wenn man Meister werden möchte.
Glaube ich nicht, weil normalerweise, wenn man den Punktezahl hat von Ajax und PSV, wird man in 19 der 20 Jahren Meister. Es ist eine normale Punktezahl, weil natürlich verliert der niederländischen Meister weniger als der deutsche Meister. Aber auch der niederländische Meister verliert spielen. Es ist nicht so, dass ein niederländischer Meister – ich glaube, dass es in der Geschichte – ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, aber ich glaube, dass es nur Ajax in 95 umgeschlagen Meister wurde und vielleicht in 72. Aber das sind Ausnahmen, das sind absolute Ausnahmen. Auch in den Niederlanden passiert es. Also ein Jahr, wie PSV und Ajax diese Saison erleben, ist normalerweise gut genug für den Titel. Und ein guter Beispiel hierfür ist auch diese Serie von Ajax Unterfrankenburg, als man viermal in Folge Meister wurde. Bevor dieser Serie war Martin Joll, auch der einmalige Trainer von Hamburger SV und Ex-Spieler von Bayern München, der damals Trainer von Eif und er hat mehr Punkte geholt, als Frank de Boer je geholt hatte. Aber er wurde kein Meister und Frank de Boer wurde Meister. Dann ist Frank de Boer fünf Jahre Trainer gewesen, weil er während der ersten Saison gekommen ist. Und in dem letzten Jahr hat er mehr Punkte gesammelt als in den vier Jahren vorher, als er Meister wurde. Aber da wurde er kein Meister, weil er es auf den letzten Spieltag verspielt hat durch ein Unentschieden bei der Grafschaft, nicht weit über die deutsche Grenze. Da hat man eins zu eins gespielt. Und dann hat man die Titel verspielt, weil an PSV das gleichzeitig gewonnen wurde. Das zeigt eigentlich auch etwas aus über diese Saison, weil wir wieder eine Saison haben, wie diesen Jahr unter Martin Joll als Twente-Meister wurde. Das war 2010. Zwei Mannschaften haben sehr viele Punkte ergattern. In der Meisterschaft gibt es zwei große Unterschiede zwischen PSV und Ajax. Das hat es in der Geschichte des Öfteren gegeben. PSV spielt unter Marc van Bommel, den man in Deutschland natürlich auch noch gut kennt. Es ist ein sehr effektives Fußball, also auch pragmatisches Fußball, wie auch Ronald Koeman das spielt. Das bedeutet, dass man auch schwächere Spiele einfach über die Runden bringt. PSV hat auch, und das muss man auch sagen, aber das braucht man, wenn man Meister werden will, auch sehr viel Glück. Man kann in dieser Saison sagen, wenn man schwach spielt und dann in der Schlussphase noch siegt, dann ist das auch Kraft, weil man geht bis zum Schluss, man macht am Ende den Unterschied, weil man doch besser ist als der Gegner usw. Und das sagt Van Bommel natürlich auch, und das ist teilweise auch wirklich der Fall, aber so oft, wie es jetzt bei PSV passiert ist, und vor allem in diesem Jahr 2019, der zweiten Hälfte der Saison, muss man auch sagen, dass es Glück ist. Den Punkt ist auch, und das sieht man auch bei PSV, dass aufmerksam ist, man hat versucht, diese Saison einen Schritt nach vorne zu machen. Etwas angriffslustiger zu spielen. Und diesen Versuch ist eigentlich nach hinten losgegangen bei PSV. Also da hat man etwas schwächer gespielt, obwohl man schöneren Fußball spielen will, habe ich das Gefühl. Und daher bin ich davon überzeugt, dass man wieder so Fußball spielen wird, wie in der ersten Hälfte der Saison am Sonntag gegen Ajax.
Genau, das ist das kommende Spitzenspiel jetzt eben.
Ja, und den Punkt ist, bei Ajax sieht man, dass Ajax anfälliger ist als PSV. Und das haben wir vor allem im Spiel gegen Feyenoord gesehen, aber das war auch ein sehr schwaches Spiel. Also so etwas passiert auch in einer Saison, aber es darf nicht passieren, weil der Punkt ist, wenn man jetzt den Unterschied in Punkte sieht, sieht man eigentlich diesen 3-0 in Eindhoven am Anfang der Saison, als Ajax verloren hat in Eindhoven. Und diese Niederlage gegen Feyenoord machen im Moment den Unterschied mit fünf Punkten. Und man muss auch sagen, in diesen Spielen hat Ajax beide Male sich selbst geschlagen.
Liegt das am Fußball von Erik Ten Hag? Unterscheidet der sich dann von dem etwas pragmatischeren Ansatz von Marc van Bommel?
Es gibt viele Sachen, die eigentlich nicht gleich sind in Amsterdam und Eindhoven. Weil es hat in der Geschichte noch mal die Besetzung auf dem Platz gegeben. Aber beide spielen 4-3-3 mit zwei Sechsen im Mittelfeld und einen Zehner. Also ein defensiv ausgerichtetes Mittelfeld. Bei beiden ist der Mann, der als Zehner spielt, mehr ein Mittelfeldspieler als ein Angreifer. Also solche Sachen sind beide gleich. Aber man sieht ab und zu, und da sieht man auch die Vereinskultur, zum Beispiel in Eindhoven, hat Ten Hag gedacht, die können unter den Druck von PSV fußballerisch rauskommen. Und da hat er zum Beispiel, Frenkie de Waal, er hat da nicht verfügen können über Matthijs de Ligt, und dann hat er Frenkie de Jong statt in Mittenfeld im Herzen der Abwehr gesetzt, um von da aus den Aufbau aufzubauen. Und eine Art, wie man das früher gesehen hat, mit zum Beispiel Franz Beckenbauer. Und ich will ihn nicht vergleichen mit Beckenbauer, aber dann versteht man die Gedanken hinter diesem Fußball. Und das ist völlig schiefgelaufen. Luc de Jong hat in diesem Herzen der Abwehr von PSV, von Ajax fast freies Spiel gehabt. Und da sah man, okay, das ist ein Einschätzungsfehler von Den Haag gewesen. Und man kann auch sagen, dass in Rotterdam ist die Mannschaft völlig eingestürzt.
Genau, also Luc de Jong ist jetzt der Stürmer, nur für diejenigen, die jetzt gerade verwirrt waren. Frenkie de Jong ist der, der dann in die Abwehr musste, der jetzt dann zum FC Barcelona wechselt wird. Luc de Jong ist der aktuell Führende in der Torschützenliste bei PSV. Vielleicht sollten wir an der Stelle dann auch mal ein bisschen über PSV noch länger reden, weil Ajax hat man ja durch die Champions League auch vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr mitbekommen, auch hier von Deutschland aus. Was zeichnet denn PSV aus, jenseits jetzt von der Art, wie Marc van Bommel das Team spielen lässt? Wer sind denn da die entscheidenden Spieler?
Ich würde bei PSV ein Wort verwenden und das ist Stahlkraft. PSV ist wirklich eine Mannschaft und wirklich eine Einheit. Und man sieht auch den Handschrift von dem Fußballspieler Marc van Bommel zurück in die Mannschaft. Es ist ein Block, der immer sehr gut steht und erst danach nachdenkt über weitere Sachen. Aber das bedeutet, dass man eigentlich gar nicht gewinnen kann von PSV. Und das ist die große Kraft dieser Mannschaft, wodurch man immer wieder schwächere Spiele gewinnt. Zweitens, und das ist auch eine wichtige Sache bei PSV, hat man einen großartigen Außenstürmer, mit Hirving Lozano und Steven Vorn. Ich glaube, dass sich über Lozano wenig zu sagen brauchen nach dem WM2003. Dass alle Deutschen wissen, wie gut er ist. Aber Bergwein ist der unbekannte, aber gleichzeitig auch ein sehr, sehr großes Talent. PSV hatte diese Saison den Pech, dass man in einer viel stärkeren Gruppe war, in der Champions League als Ajax. Mit Inter, mit Spurs und mit Barcelona. Da ist man normalerweise, so muss man das auch sagen, letzten der Gruppe geworden. Und da ist es auch schwer, sich zu unterscheiden. Aber daher ist Bergwein weniger in Erscheinung getreten, aber er ist absolut ein super Talent. Und man hat auch gesehen, dass mit seiner Hereinnahme das Länderspiel sich auch gedreht hat. Aber die beiden sind schnell technisch versiert, haben alles von einem modernen Angreifer. Und dann haben die auch dann noch in der Mitte einen wirklichen Zentralstürmer. Und lass es mal so sagen, ich kann verstehen, dass man das in Deutschland schwieriger findet, um zu verstehen, weil Luke de Jong natürlich nicht den Durchbruch geschafft hat bei Borussia München. Aber ein Spieler kann sich auch weiterentwickeln. Und das hat Luke de Jong absolut getan. Und um mal ein Beispiel dafür zu geben, in unserer Nationalmannschaft hat man eine Position für den Jokers. Und dafür kann man wählen zwischen Luke de Jong und Wout Weghorst. Aber, bekannt in Deutschland, aber Ronald Koeman hat in der ganzen Saison den Vorzug gegeben an Luke de Jong im Gegensatz zu Wout Weghorst. Also kann man das vielleicht am besten erklären für Deutsche, es ist der etwas bessere Wout Weghorst. Ja, und da kann man als auch jemanden, der nicht wöchentlich die Eredivisie sieht, kann dann doch verstehen, dass er doch ein guter Mittelstürmer ist, der auf unserem Niveau in der Eredivisie absolut den Unterschied macht. Und dann zwischen zwei so guten Außenstürmer, dann hat man absolut alles dafür, um eine Meistermannschaft zu haben. Und dann diesen Block von Spielern dahinter. Und dabei will ich auch sagen, dass Spiele sich auch großartig entwickeln, unter Marc van Bommel. Man hat auch in der Nationalmannschaft in Denzel Dunfries gesehen, der ist im Sommer von Heerenveen gekommen. Und der ist wirklich jemandem, der international als Rechtsaußenverteidiger absolut mithalten kann. Pablo Rosario ist noch ersatz, ist auch eine Entdeckung dieser Saison. Aber vielleicht auch, was deutschen Auchstaunen wird, Daniel Schwaab. Der war unter den Vorgängern nicht so super wichtig, als er jetzt ist. Aber unter Marc van Bommel ist er absolut ein Starkhalter. Er war mal U21 Europameister, wenn ich mich gut erinnere. Aber er hat diesen Versprechen jetzt wirklich eingelöst. Es gibt einen Block dahinten. Und der eine der Köpfe von diesem Block ist absolut Daniel Schwaab.
Denen wir von Leverkusen und Stuttgart noch kennen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn es bei euch jetzt nur leiser geklingelt hat in diesem Moment. PSV, die Defensive, absolut beeindruckend. 16 Gegentreffer, erst eine Niederlage in dieser Saison. Das ist das, was du vorhin angedeutet hast. Nicht Ajax spielt eine schlechte Saison. Die von PSV ist noch besser als die von Ajax. Und deswegen hat man jetzt eben diese 5 Punkte Vorsprung. Und am Sonntag treffen beide dann in Amsterdam aufeinander. Jetzt haben wir ja aber noch viele Mannschaften dahinter, nur ein begrenztes Zeitbudget allerdings. Wer sind denn so die Teams, wo du sagst, da wäre es jetzt noch sinnvoll, dass wir drüber sprechen? Wer spielt noch eine für dich bemerkenswerte Saison?
Dann muss man einiges sagen. Dann will ich absolut Feyenoord erwähnen, weil Feyenoord ist absolut unsere Nummer 2 des Landes. Wir haben am Sonntag...
Die Nummer 2 oder die Nummer 3?
Nein, die in Popularität, in Größe und Größe.
Ach so, okay.
Das ist die absolute Nummer 2 des Landes. Also das absolute Spiel der Spiele der Niederlande ist Ajax-Feyenoord oder Feyenoord-Ajax. Viel mehr noch als PSV. Aber Feyenoord hat ein super Stadion, aber dieser Stadion ist verältet und kann daher nicht mehr mithalten mit diesen beiden. Das ist auch ein Teil, wie jedes Land auch Probleme hat. Ich glaube auch, dass es für uns wichtig ist, dass Feyenoord wieder Anschluss findet bei Ajax und PSV. Das ist leider nicht der Fall. Und wenn man dann über den niederländischen Fußball redet, dann redet man natürlich immer über Talente. Weil bei uns sieht man die Stars der Zukunft. Wenn man jetzt in die Eredivisie guckt, dann sieht man die Spieler, die in vier, fünf Jahren in Europa führend sind. Und dann möchte ich doch noch einen unerwarteten Namen sagen, weil er war sehr groß, als er 16 war. Martin Ödegaard, das ist ein Freund von Real Madrid. Aber er hat natürlich den Durchbruch nicht geschafft, weil er es schon am Anfang nach Ajax oder PSV gegeben hat. Aber jetzt ist er erstens ausgeliehen worden an Heeren Wehn und jetzt an Vitesse Arnhem. Und Ödegaard ist wirklich auf dem Weg, auch dieses Versprechen zu erreichen, dass er wirklich auch jetzt den Durchbruch schafft. Und daher glaube ich auch, dass er vielleicht nächste Saison schon wieder bei einem Spitzenclub in einem kleineren Land oder einem Mittelclub in einem größeren Land spielen kann. Dann haben wir auch Lizo Douan, der mit Tim Handwerker und Julian Chabot spielt bei FC Groningen. Das ist ein japanischer Nationalspieler, der absolut vielversprechend ist und der wahrscheinlich auch in einigen Jahren die Welt erobern wird. Und dann finde ich auch die Arbeit von AZ Altma herausragend, weil AZ kämpft mit Feyenoord um den dritten Platz in der Eredivisie. Dass man es schon so lange macht, macht man als hervorragende Arbeit. Und AZ bringt auch immer wieder große Talente hervor. Und ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist auch der Fakt, dass Real Madrid heutzutage die Leute aus der Jugendarbeit von Madrid immer auch Studien reisen. Und dann gehen die auch wie alle nach Ajax, nach Feyenoord, nach PSV, aber vor allem Ajax. Aber Real Madrid hat auch wirklich jetzt Augen für, was in Alkmaar passiert. Und ist schon verschiedene Male da gewesen und wollen eigentlich alles wissen, was da los ist. Und daher glaube ich auch, dass man wirklich eine Ausnahmeausbildung hat. Und da sieht man auch großartige Talente wie Gusteal und Coop Miners, aber vor allem Kelvin Steens. Kelvin Steens ist auch ein Außenstürmer oder Andries-Ruske-Mittenfeldspieler, glaube ich vielleicht, was er auch gut spielen könnte. Aber das wird auch einer. Und er ist sehr lange verletzt gewesen. Und davon hat er sich jetzt zurückgekämpft. Und daher dauert seine Entwicklung etwas länger vielleicht als andere, die man in den Niederlanden kennt. Aber in einigen Jahren wird ganz Europa auch wissen, dass Kelvin Steens da ist. Und das unterstreicht auch, was eigentlich in allgemeiner Hinsicht in den Niederlanden los ist. Weil das hat Peter Bosch letzte Woche sehr gut gesagt. Man kann noch so eine gute Jugendarbeit haben. Aber in einem Land wie die Niederlande, das gleich groß ist wie Nordrhein-Westfalen, ist man immer abhängig auch von Talent. Von Jungs, die von einem Vater und einer Mutter auf die Welt gesetzt wurden und das Talent, das sie dann haben. Und jetzt haben die Niederlande wieder eine neue Generation, die kommen ist, mit auch wieder verschiedene neue Großtalente.
Aber macht denn die Niederlande etwas anders als jetzt andere Länder deiner Meinung nach, dass ja doch die Quote an Top-Talenten aus dieser Gesamtmasse, die wir jetzt einfach mal Nordrhein-Westfalen nennen, so viel höher ist als in anderen Ländern? Woran liegt das?
Das hat wahrscheinlich uns – das ist natürlich eine Frage. Und Trainer werden immer sagen, das hat mit unserer Arbeit zu tun. Und das ist glaube ich teilweise auch so, weil man sehr darauf beachtet. Aber wenn man auch sieht, dass die Generation, die in 1880 Europameister wurde, die stand als eine Zeit, dass die Jugendarbeit sehr viel Kritik hat einstecken müssen. Und also dann kann man auch sagen, war die Jugendarbeit damals so gut? Oder gab es nur diese Talente?
Oder war der Rest Europas einfach noch so schlecht? Die Niederlande hatten ja schon immer oder sehr lange einen taktischen Vorteil. Weil die Art und Weise, den Fußball zu denken, viel mehr mit dem Raum zu tun hatte, viel mehr mit sauberer Passstruktur, mit Ballbesitzspiel und Positionsspiel, hatten die Niederlande einen Vorteil gegenüber ganz vielen anderen Nationen und dann auch Vereinsmannschaften. Von außen betrachtet würde ich sagen, dieser taktische Vorteil hat sich nivelliert, weil inzwischen andere Vereine dazugelernt haben. Und jetzt kann man eben quasi nicht mehr über die Taktik den Gegner schlagen. Jetzt ist die Frage, welchen Vorteil können sich niederländische Mannschaften jetzt noch herausarbeiten, außer dass sie immer mal wieder einen Frankie de Jong haben, den sie aber immer nur so lange begleiten dürfen, bis er eigentlich so anfängt zu glitzern. Und richtig strahlen wird er dann wahrscheinlich beim FC Barcelona.
Aber das ist der Unterschied mit den 70er-Jahren, als Ajax noch die Welt beherrschen konnte. Und heutzutage, das wird einem niederländischen Verein nie mehr gelingen. Aber man kann auch sagen, dass die Niederlande, weil wir klein sind, auch künstlere Abstände haben, wodurch wir auch vielleicht weniger Talent durch die Lappen gehen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, wenn ich in einem Dorf in Norddeutschland wohne, wie gut der deutschen Fußball auch ist. Aber es ist für all diese Profifreine in Deutschland sehr schwer, all diese Dörfer zu sehen und all diese Talente zu betrachten. Da sieht man auch einen großen Unterschied. Wir haben unglaublich viele aktive Fußballer. Ich habe mal gesagt, wenn man die Fußballkultur eines Landes kennenlernen will, muss man den Film anschauen, der über den Fußball gemacht wird. So hat England Viva Pitch, wo es vor allem darüber geht, wie man Anhänger eines Vereins ist. So hat Deutschland das Wunder von Bern, wobei man wieder die Stahlkraft der Deutschen sah von zurückkämpfen unter allen Umständen, was Deutschland ausmacht, was wir auch letzten Sonntag wieder gesehen haben. Aber die Niederlande haben einen Film, der wird genannt All-Stars, und das geht über den Amateur-Fußball, über all diese Mannschaften. Und davon haben wir mehr als eine Million aktive Fußballspieler. Und daher sind die Niederlande so organisiert und gibt es – das wird wahrscheinlich auch in einigen anderen Ländern sein, aber weniger organisiert – jedes Kind in den Niederlanden fängt an, wenn er vier oder fünf ist, mit Fußball spielen. Und das macht er auch gleich in einem Verein, auf einem guten Fußballplatz. Jedes Kind spielt auf einem natürlichen Grasrasen oder einem künstlichen Rasen. Aber der Untergrund, worauf er spielt, ist für jedes Kind gut. Jeder Verein hat ein gutes Vereinsheim und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass diese Struktur auch dafür sorgt, dass fast keinem Jungen durch die Lappen geht. Und in anderen Ländern, wo man weniger strukturiert arbeitet, glaube ich, dass Talente eher nicht gesehen werden als bei uns.
Ja, das ist sicherlich der eine Aspekt. Und wahrscheinlich kommt dann noch mit dazu, dass die Niederlande auch einfach aus ihrer Tradition heraus einen anderen Umgang mit Talent haben. Also in Deutschland möchte man immer die Talente, aber einen Leroy Sané findet man eigentlich erst dann richtig gut, wenn er auch bei Manchester City spielt und da richtig gut ist.
Aber da ist auch ein Unterschied, weil für mich das absolut schön an Deutschland ist. Und daher bin ich auch nicht für, was jetzt passiert, dass Bayern die Liga so überherzt. Aber die Spannung macht die Bundesliga aus. Und die Spannung macht einen großen Unterschied. Aber das bedeutet auch, dass ich glaube, nur in diesem Jahrhundert schon acht oder neun Teilnehmer am europäischen Fußball abgestiegen sind aus der Bundesliga. Und das bedeutet, dass wenn man Trainer ist in der Bundesliga, hat man auch keine Zeit, um Talente einzusetzen. Um mal zu sagen, okay, ich baue in zwei Jahren eine Mannschaft auf. Dann ist man schon abgestiegen. In den Niederlanden hat man auch die Räume, um Talente einzusetzen, weil vor allem die Großklubs steigen sowieso nicht ab. Aber auch die Mittelvereine sind nicht so abstiegsgefeiert, wie man das in Deutschland ist. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die das eine Jahr sechster wird und das Jahr danach siebzehnt. Daher hat man auch Zeit, um Talente gewöhnen zu lassen, um Rollen und Spiele zu geben. Ein gutes Beispiel, das Deutsche vielleicht kennen, ist Michael Rensingh. Er wurde immer von Uli Hoeneß gesagt, das ist der neue Nationaltorhüter, weil wir haben das größte Talent. Aber er hat nie gespielt. Und als er das endlich nach all diesen Jahren gespielt hat, wurde er gleich wieder nach drei schwächeren Spielen abgeschossen. Ein niederländisches Verein hat die Zeit, um so einen Spieler auch einzusetzen, Spielpraxis zu geben und sich auch zu entwickeln. Und wenn er das nicht bei Ajax, Feyenoord oder PSV kann, dann kann er das jedenfalls bei Vitesse oder AZ oder Groningen. Und das ist glaube ich das Allerwichtigste, dass unsere Talente auch ab ihrem 17. 18. auf dem höchsten Niveau in den Niederlanden Spielpraxis bekommen und auch sich entwickeln können, weil sie sehr viel spielen auch gegen Erwachsene.
Okay, ja das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Das bringt mich auch noch mal ein letztes Mal zurück zur Liga, bevor wir dann leider schon Schluss machen müssen. Wenn ich mir eben angucke, wir haben das Spitzenspiel, also den Kampf um die Meisterschaft, haben wir angesprochen. Wir haben auch schon angesprochen, dass Feyenoord und Alkmaa gerade punktgleich liegen. Da geht es dann um die Frage der Champions-League-Qualifikation. Dahinter Vitesse… Ja, genau, völlig richtig. Und dahinter dann Vitesse, Utrecht und Heracles. Die bilden so eine Dreierreihe, die dann schon ein bisschen Abstand hat. Allerdings, wenn ich mir den Abstiegskampf angucke, dann finde ich, ist er in dieser Saison, zumindest jetzt, Stand 26. Spieltag, doch noch einigermaßen spannend. Denn wir haben vom Vorletzten bis zum Platz 12, haben wir nur vier Punkte. Und da hängen ganz viele Mannschaften mit dabei, die mir nicht so viel sagen. Zwolle, Sittard, dann Den Haag, Excelsior, de Graafschap und Emmen. Wie gestaltet sich gerade der Abstiegskampf? Wer ist da überraschend mit hinten drin?
Überraschend mit hinten drin ist absolut Zwolle, der während der Saison Jaap Stam auch als Trainer angestellt hat. Jaap Stam ist da Trainer, der kommt während der Saison. Das ist eine absolute Überraschung. Auch dass NAC Breda so weit abgeschlagen ist, ist eine Überraschung. Und dass der Grafschap, Emmen und Sittard da drin stecken, ist etwas zu erwarten. Und das bedeutet, dass einen und ich fürchte auch, dass aus diesen drei zwei auch in den Aufabstieg müssen. Ich glaube, dass die anderen sich doch noch retten werden, weil die etwas mehr Talent haben. Vielleicht dass Excelsior noch dreien fällt, weil die haben auch einen schwierigen Stand diese Saison. Aber das sind wirklich doch die Freine, in denen es geht, in den Abstieg. Und man sieht zum Beispiel auch, Groningen war lange drin und hat dann eine Serie gemacht und ist dann auch wieder draus gegangen. Und das ist der Unterschied, dass es eigentlich nur wenige Mannschaften da gibt, die man da nicht erwartet hatte. Und das bedeutet, dass man viele Freine hat, wo man auf Jugend einsetzen kann, ohne diese Angst haben zu müssen. Und man sieht zum Beispiel auch, wenn man dann doch über die niederländische Liga redet, dass zum Beispiel auch verschiedene englische Vereine zusammenarbeiten mit niederländischen Vereinen, um dann auch Spieler in der niederländischen Spielpraxis zu geben. Zum Beispiel Chelsea hat eine offene Linie mit Vitesse, das ist ein bekanntes Beispiel. Und Manchester City hat auch viele Jugendspieler in der Niederlande, die dann hier Spielpraxis sammeln sollen.
Kannst du dir erklären, warum es ähnliche Konstellationen nicht mit der Bundesliga gibt?
Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass die Bundesliga zu nah dran ist in Qualität an den englischen Ligern. Und du meinst jetzt zwischen niederländischen und deutschen Vereinen.
Ja genau, das meine ich.
Das ist glaube ich ein Fehler der Deutschen. Die haben das glaube ich nicht gut genug gesehen, weil ich glaube, dass auch viele deutsche Talente, die jetzt auf der Bank schmoren oder meistens gar nicht im Kader sind, sich besser entwickeln in der Eredivisie als in den Regionalligern. Und der Punkt ist auch, einige Spitzenvereine haben auch keine Regionalliga-Mannschaft mehr. Also, ja, ich würde sagen, das ist etwas, worin auch die Jugendausbildung in Deutschland sich verbessern kann, wenn man mit Vereinen aus dem Beispiel die Niederlande, Belgien oder Portugal zusammenarbeitet und da auch ihre Talente einsetzt. Es gibt eine Ausnahme übrigens, da hat auch diese Woche, oder letzte Woche, Kieker mal wieder drüber geschrieben, Tim Handwerker bei FC Groningen.
Ja, genau, aber eine von ganz wenigen Ausnahmen.
Ja, da sieht man auch zum Beispiel den Unterschied zwischen Tim Handwerker am Anfang, als er angefangen hat in Groningen, und jetzt, ist auch riesig. Köln bekommt wirklich einen anderen Spieler zurück, als dass er in den Niederlanden angefangen hat.
Genau, und die Vereine, die dann irgendwie eine örtliche Nähe zu den Niederlanden haben, die haben das noch ein bisschen mehr auf dem Schirn, ich sitze ja hier unten in München da. Braucht man die Leute nicht über die Ehre, die diese befragen, aber dann wundern sich immer alle, warum da so viele Talente herkommen und in Deutschland sich so viel verändert. Ach Jan, ich könnte ewig mit dir weiterreden, wir müssen das vielleicht einfach nochmal zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt machen. Ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Man kann dir folgen auf Twitter als etjanlerkes. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst. Das freut mich sehr. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 124. Und wenn Jan hier schon über niederländische Fußballfilme erzählt, dann kann ich berichten. Hört doch das Tribütengespräch zu Fußballfilmen, das wir vor einigen Wochen aufgezeichnet haben. Das ist das vorletzte erschienene Rasenfunk-Tribütengespräch. Da geht es dann auch viel um Fußballfilme. Wir hören uns wieder in der nächsten Sendung. Bis dahin habt eine gute Zeit.